Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Was haben Hermine aus Harry Potter,
die Crew von Star Trek
und Doctor Who gemeinsam?
Sie alle können zeitreisen.
In die Vergangenheit, Zukunft,
oder beides.
Zeitreisen spielen im
Science-Fiction-Bereich eine Rolle,
und in der Wissenschaft.
Wie genau, das klären wir,
und beantworten die Fragen:
Warum ein Wurmloch ein Portal
in die Vergangenheit sein könnte.
Warum ihr dort nie
eure Großväter töten könntet.
Wie Forschende in der realen Welt
Ausschau nach Zeitreisenden halten.
Das alles gibt es genau ... jetzt.
*dramatische Musik*
Zeitreisen ist ein All-Time-Favorit
im Bereich Science-Fiction.
"Die Zeitmaschine" von H. G. Wells
ist der Klassiker.
1895 erschienen.
Seitdem wurden die verrücktesten
fiktiven Zeitmaschinen gebaut.
Telefonzellen scheinen
sich besonders gut zu eignen.
Leider gibt's
im echten Leben noch keine.
Wir haben uns gefragt,
wie wissenschaftlich akkurat
sind solche Zeitreisefilme?
Ist Zeitreise physikalisch möglich?
Was würde passieren,
wenn wir eine Zeitmaschine bauen?
Würden wir damit
das Universum durcheinanderbringen?
Das klären wir
mit den Wissenschaftspodcastlern
Nicolas Wöhrl und Reinhard Remfort.
Nicolas und Reinhard sind Physiker
und seit 2013 die Hosts des Podcasts
"Methodisch inkorrekt!".
Sie sind nicht das 1. Mal bei uns.
Sie haben schon den Rathausblitz aus
"Zurück in die Zukunft" gecheckt.
Mit Nicolas sprechen wir
übers Reisen in die Zukunft.
Den Anfang macht Reinhard,
wir drehen die Uhren rückwärts.
Willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Ich freue mich, dass ihr da seid.
Beim letzten Dreh war es saukalt.
Ich spüre meine Füße wieder
und wir sind diesmal drinnen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Diesmal geht's.
Letztes Mal saßt ihr im DeLorean,
in einer klassischen Zeitmaschine.
In der fiktionalen Welt
gibt es noch andere Methoden,
um in die Vergangenheit zu kommen.
Bei "Rubinrot"
sind es Zeitreisengene.
Die Avengers im MCU
nutzen fiktive Elementarteilchen
und Quantenmechanik,
Was hat die Wissenschaft
dem denn entgegenzusetzen?
Eigentlich nicht so viel.
Zeitreisen
sind nicht unrealistisch.
Wenn man sich an die Grundlagen
der Relativitätstheorie hält,
spricht erst mal nichts dagegen.
Wenn wir das theoretisch angehen,
was sagt die Theorie aus?
Die Relativitätstheorie beschreibt
die Struktur von Raum und Zeit.
Die ist anders,
als wir sie im Alltag wahrnehmen.
Wir nehmen Raum und Zeit
getrennt war,
und nicht als zusammengehörig.
In der Realitätstheorie sieht man,
dass es keine getrennte Zeit
gibt vom Raum.
Sondern es ist eine Einheit,
die Raumzeit.
Ein 4-dimensionaler Vektor mit
3 Orts- und einer Zeitkoordinate.
Selbst die Raumzeit
ist nicht überall gleich,
sondern es kommt darauf an,
wie schnell man sich bewegt.
Wie schnell sich
2 Beobachter zueinander bewegen.
Wenn ein Astronaut im Raumschiff
sich schnell bewegt,
dann vergeht
bei dem die Zeit langsamer,
für einen Beobachter,
der das Raumschiff beobachtet.
Das wird gern genutzt
in Zeitreisefilmen.
Das sehen wir
im Film "Planet der Affen",
ein Zeitreisen-Klassiker.
Da ist der Astronaut so unterwegs,
wie du es beschreibst.
In einem Raumschiff
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Da hat er eine Anzeige im Cockpit
um diese verschiedenen Zeiten
vom Raumschiff im Vergleich zur Erde
zu vergleichen.
Hat er ernsthaft eine Zigarre
auf dem Armaturenbrett abgelegt?
Das ist total weird irgendwie.
Raumfahrt!
Das ist unrealistisch,
der Rest aber gar nicht so falsch.
Im Grunde ist das möglich,
was dort gezeigt wird.
Das Phänomen nennt sich:
Wird in der Relativitätstheorie
beschrieben.
Die Zeit ist nicht
für sich alleine stehend.
Sondern die Zeit
ist relativ für den Beobachter.
Wenn ein Raumschiff
sich schnell bewegt,
dann gehen die Uhren dort für einen
Beobachter auf der Erde langsamer.
Die Zeit vergeht anders.
Das Phänomen kommt nicht nur
im Film vor, auch in der Realität.
Im Alltag nicht so oft,
es sei denn, man ist Astronaut.
Auf der ISS kann man das messen.
Die ISS hämmert mit 28.000 km/h
um die Erde rum.
Das ist schnell genug, dass man
die Zeitdehnung messen kann.
Das sind nur Sekundenbruchteile,
aber es ist real,
nicht nur Theorie.
Wie kann man dieses Wissen nutzen,
um ein Modell zu haben,
mit dem wir
in die Vergangenheit kommen?
Die Relativitätstheorie
ist erst mal eine Theorie,
die mathematisch beschrieben wird
durch:
Diese Gleichungen beschreiben
die Struktur der Raumzeit,
wie die mit Energie zusammenhängt,
mit Materie und so weiter.
Diese Gleichungen sind das,
dafür gibt's verschiedene Lösungen.
Eine mögliche Lösung wäre die,
die von Kurt Gödel
1949 formuliert wurde.
Im Rahmen dieser Lösung
ist es möglich,
dass Energie und Materie
rückwärts durch die Zeit reisen.
Und zwar auf sogenannten:
Okay, closed timelike Curves.
Klingt erst mal
nach einer Zeitschleife.
Wie in
"Täglich grüßt das Murmeltier".
Da ist Bill Murray gefangen
in einem Zeitloop,
erlebt immer wieder denselben Tag.
Du musst mich ins Boot holen,
ist das so was?
Was genau sind
closed timelike Curves?
Dazu muss man weiter ausholen
und den Begriff der Weltlinie
einführen.
Das ist der Weg, den ein Objekt
durch die Raumzeit nimmt.
Dargestellt wird das in einem
2-dimensionalen Koordinatensystem.
Eine Achse ist da für die Zeit,
die andere für den Raum.
Angenommen, wir betrachten
den Raum, in dem wir uns befinden,
die nächsten 5 Minuten.
Ich stehe an einem Fleck,
und das ist meine Weltlinie.
Die geht entlang der Zeitachse,
bewegt sich nicht im Raum.
Wenn ich mich
mit konstanter Geschwindigkeit
durch den Raum bewege, könnte
meine Weltlinie so aussehen.
Eine closed timelike Curve
ist im Grunde eine Weltlinie,
die sich durch die Raumzeit bewegt
und an einen Ort zurückkehrt,
wo sie schon mal war,
also ein geschlossener Ring.
Wenn ich mich auf einer
closed timelike Curve befinde,
läuft für mich
die Zeit normal vorwärts.
Aber ich lande irgendwann
in meiner Vergangenheit,
und es geht von vorne los.
Das klingt in der Theorie
erst mal simpel.
Aber wie realistisch ist das?
Also wir betreiben hier
theoretische Physik.
Das sind mathematische Gleichungen,
Differenzialgleichungen,
die die Struktur
der Raumzeit beschreiben.
Wir haben die Relativitätstheorie
in etlichen Experimenten bestätigt,
aber trotzdem ist es
ein rein mathematisches Konstrukt.
Das heißt,
es gibt mehrere Lösungen dafür.
Bei diesen Lösungen
sind immer Randbedingungen,
die gegeben sein müssen.
Bei dieser Theorie von Gödel
müsste das Universum rotieren.
Aber wir haben keine Anzeichen,
dass das Universum rotiert.
Ähnlich ist das
bei diesen closed timelike Curves.
Man kann glauben, das wäre wie bei
"Täglich grüßt das Murmeltier".
Ist aber nicht so,
wenn man die Gleichung anguckt,
kommt man zu einem Punkt
der Raumzeit zurück.
Was aber nicht bedeutet,
dass man in einer Schleife ist,
sondern auch
anders weitergehen könnte.
They are gone!
They are all gone!
Today is tomorrow.
Okay, dann fällt das eher raus.
Lass uns mal
einen anderen Ansatz angucken,
nämlich von dem Netflix-Film
"The Adam Project".
Da hat der Protagonist Adam
einen Jet,
damit kann er auch zeitreisen,
nutzt ihn als Zeitmaschine.
Er bewegt sich durch Wurmlöcher.
Wurmlöcher kennen wir
jetzt vor allen Dingen
so als Shortcut
zwischen Positionen im Raum.
Aber könnte man die
auch als Shortcut
zwischen Abschnitten
in der Zeit benutzen?
Also ganz wichtig erst mal,
ist pure Theorie,
weil da sind wir an den Grenzen
vom mathematischen Modell.
Aber angenommen,
es gäbe Wurmlöcher.
Wir haben noch nie
irgendwo eins gemessen.
Aber angenommen, es gäbe sie,
dann könnte man die
auch zum Zeitreisen nutzen.
Wir haben gesagt
Raum und Zeit sind nicht getrennt.
Du sagst, als Shortcut
durch den Raum benutzen.
Dann ist es auch
ein Shortcut durch die Zeit.
Wie würden wir das machen?
Im Grunde ist es einfach,
wir müssen nur Wurmlöcher erzeugen,
die Enden manipulieren
und das Ganze aufrechterhalten.
Okay, sehr moderate Annahmen.
Wenn das möglich wäre,
diese einfachen Annahmen,
dann könnten wir damit
eine Zeitmaschine bauen.
Wir lassen ein Ende vom Wurmloch
auf der Erde liegen,
und das andere Ende nehmen wir mit
im fast lichtschnellen Raumschiff.
Und hämmern damit durchs All.
Wenn wir uns mit
fast Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen,
dann wird die Zeit
anders vergehen als auf der Erde,
wo das andere Ende ist.
Während bei uns
ein paar Minuten vergangen sind,
sind auf der Erde
Jahrhunderte vergangen.
Was wir bei "Planet der Affen"
gesehen haben.
Das heißt, wenn wir mit
diesem Raumschiff wieder umdrehen,
auf der Zukunftserde ankommen,
dann haben wir,
weil die Löcher synchronisiert sind,
ein Portal von der Zukunftserde
in die Vergangenheit.
Aber wir können nicht weiter
zurückreisen als zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo das Loch erzeugt wurde.
Ja, das stimmt.
Damit haut das im Film
auch nicht so ganz hin.
Denn da ist es so, dass sie aus 2050
zurückreisen nach 2018,
wo gerade mal der Grundstein
für das Zeitreisen gelegt wurde
und noch
gar kein Wurmloch existiert.
Schade, aber ich würde sagen,
sehr close dran,
"The Adam Project".
It's a complicated issue.
Wenn wir die Wurmloch-Sache
in die Zukunft vertagen.
Und da alles entstehen könnte.
Dann ist das vielleicht
auch eine Erklärung dafür,
dass es noch keine anderen
Zeitreisen-Mechanismen gibt.
Und das ist der Grund, warum wir
keine Zeitreisen-Touristen sehen.
Sonst würden wir
ständig Leuten begegnen,
die mit einer anderen Art
von Zeitreise hier gelandet sind.
Ja, im Grunde schon.
Ist ein interessanter Aspekt.
Das haben ein paar Forscher
2014 tatsächlich untersucht,
ob es Zeitreisen-Touristen gibt,
und wir es nicht gemerkt haben.
Die haben sich
große Weltereignisse angeguckt.
So was wie die Wahl des Papstes
oder ein Komet,
der plötzlich aufgetaucht ist.
Und haben geguckt,
ob es im Google-Suchverlauf
Suchanfragen zu diesem Thema gab,
bevor es überhaupt eingetreten ist.
Also haben nennenswert viele Leute
Papst Franziskus gegoogelt,
bevor er wirklich gewählt wurde?
Und geguckt, ob es da
Hinweise gibt zu Zeitreisen.
Was haben die herausgefunden?
Ja, nix.
Gibt es wohl nicht.
Schade.
Erinnert mich an Stephen Hawking.
Der hat mal zu einer Party
für Zeitreisende eingeladen,
die Einladungen aber
einen Tag später rausgeschickt.
Da müssen wir festhalten,
Zeitreisen in die Vergangenheit
gibt es für uns leider erst mal
nur auf dem Taschenrechner.
Nicolas, schön, dass du da bist.
Schön, dass ich hier sein darf.
Reinhard hat keine Hoffnung gemacht
für Reisen in die Vergangenheit.
Was ist mit Reisen in die Zukunft?
Gute Nachricht, ist kein Problem.
Willst du in die Zukunft reisen?
Ja.
Okay, Moment.
Wir sind angekommen.
Klugscheißerisch,
aber streng genommen stimmt das.
Wir reisen
die ganze Zeit in die Zukunft,
und zwar
mit einer Sekunde pro Sekunde.
Wir hätten es gern dramatischer,
wie es in Filmen präsentiert wird.
Wie ist es, wenn wir
weit in die Zukunft reisen wollen?
Wir haben gerade gesehen,
es gibt eine Möglichkeit,
wenn wir
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit reisen.
Im Raumschiff
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit
vergeht deine Zeit relativ
zu anderen Personen langsamer.
Du bewegst dich in die Zukunft.
Wir Physiker sagen,
relativistische Effekte,
die setzen bei 50%
der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ein.
Wenn man sich anguckt,
was haben wir denn schon erreicht?
Das schnellste,
was bisher da oben rumfliegt,
ist die Parker Solar Probe.
Die fliegt im Moment
mit 586.000 km/h.
Klingt schnell,
selbst für deutsche Autobahnen.
Aber ins Verhältnis gesetzt
zur Lichtgeschwindigkeit
ist es fast enttäuschend.
Das ist nämlich
nur 0,05% der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Noch weit weg von
echten relativistischen Effekten.
Das heißt,
man bräuchte neue Technologie,
um das zu erreichen?
Ja, genau.
Wenn wir als Menschheit
zu den Sternen aufbrechen wollen,
müssen wir viel Zeit mitbringen,
weil die Reise lange dauert.
Oder wir brauchen
echte, neue Antriebstechnologie,
weil das reicht einfach nicht.
Ich bin optimistisch als Physiker.
Wir werden
neue Antriebstechnologien haben
und dann wirklich aufbrechen,
mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Es gibt noch
eine andere Möglichkeit.
Große Massen lassen
die Zeit auch langsamer vergehen.
Wenn du dich in der Nähe
einer großen Masse befindest,
dann vergeht deine Zeit langsamer,
du reist relativ in die Zukunft.
Das ist prominent dargestellt,
nämlich im Film "Interstellar".
Da reisen die in die Zukunft,
wenn auch unbeabsichtigt,
z.B. in dieser Szene.
Die Astronauten Cooper und Emilia
sind mit einem Shuttle
auf einem Planeten unterwegs.
Dann kommen sie
zurück zum Mutterschiff.
Obwohl sie nur
kurz auf dem Planeten waren,
sind auf dem Mutterschiff
und relativ auf der Erde
schon Jahre vergangen.
I waited.
Im Film wird es erklärt,
dass sich der Planet nah
an einem Schwarzen Loch befindet.
Und die Uhren
unterschiedlich ticken.
Auf der Oberfläche des Planeten
läuft die Zeit langsamer ab
als auf dem Mutterschiff
und der Erde.
Every hour we spent on that planet
will be ...
7 years back on earth.
Ist das realistisch dargestellt?
Realistisch ist so eine Sache
bei Science-Fiction-Filmen.
Du bist in einem Planetensystem,
was wir noch nie beobachtet haben.
Die reisen durch Wurmlöcher,
auch Wurmlöcher haben wir
noch nie beobachtet.
Aber beides ist theoretisch möglich
nach der allgemeinen
Relativitätstheorie.
Dann wärst du
in der Nähe von großen Massen,
von dem Schwarzen Loch,
würde die Zeit langsam vergehen.
Das ist experimentell nachgewiesen.
Ja, zum Glück
nicht mit einem Schwarzen Loch.
Wir haben
in der Nähe der Erde keins.
Allerdings
reicht die Masse der Erde aus,
um diesen Effekt zu messen.
Das haben 2 Wissenschaftler 1959
an der Harvard-Universität
experimentell nachgewiesen.
Die haben 2 Uhren genommen
und ein hohes Haus, 22 Meter hoch.
Sie haben eine Uhr
in den Keller getan
und ein Uhr
22 Meter höher ins Penthouse.
Sie konnten messen,
dass die Uhr im Keller
etwas langsamer gegangen ist.
1,6 Billionstelsekunde pro Tag.
Das ist ein akademischer Wert
und nicht wirklich groß,
aber es konnte gemessen werden.
Faszinierend, dass es
auf der Erde nachweisbar ist.
Das ist
trotzdem verschwindend gering.
Aber der Effekt wird stärker,
je weiter man von der Erde weggeht.
Genau, dann wird es interessant.
Denk mal an GPS-Satelliten.
Die fliegen auf einer Höhe
von 20.000 Kilometern.
Und dann wird es
wirklich technisch relevant.
Die Uhren auf diesen GPS-Satelliten
laufen pro Tag
40 Mikrosekunden schneller.
Das musst du mitberechnen,
wenn du Messungen machst.
GPS-Satelliten berechnen deine
Position über Laufunterschiede,
also über Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Da machen 40 Mikrosekunden
schon einen Unterschied
in der Ortsmessung dann auch.
Total faszinierend,
dass das Auswirkung auf das hat,
was wir tagtäglich benutzen.
Bei "Interstellar
ist es natürlich total krass.
Da ist eine Stunde auf dem Planeten
7 Jahre auf der Erde.
Ist das irgendwie
machbar im Universum?
Bei "Interstellar" ist dieser
Effekt bis ins Extrem getrieben.
Dem Regisseur Christopher Nolan
war wichtig,
diese extreme Zeitdilatation
darzustellen.
Ich rechne ihm hoch an, dass er
einen Physiker ins Team geholt hat.
Kip Thorne, nicht nur Physiker,
sondern auch Nobelpreisträger.
Der sollte die Frage klären:
Ist das denkbar,
wie es im Film gezeigt wird?
Kip Thorne hat dazu
auch ein Buch geschrieben,
"The Science of Interstellar".
Ich finde faszinierend,
dass er sich wissenschaftlich
mit dieser Fragestellung
beschäftigt hat.
Ist es möglich, so eine starke
Zeitdilatation herbeizuführen?
Er hat das System
ins Extrem getrieben.
Er hat den Planeten möglichst nah
an das Schwarze Loch rangeführt.
Hat mit einberechnet, dass
das Schwarze Loch in sich rotiert,
und zwar extrem schnell.
Die Idee von dieser Rotation
ist nicht,
dass sich die Zeitdilatation
ändert.
Aber durch die hohe Rotation
des Schwarzen Lochs
realisierst du
stabilere Umlaufbahn des Planeten,
die noch näher
am Schwarzen Loch liegen.
Dadurch erhöhst du
wieder die Zeitdilatation.
Damit vergeht die Zeit
noch mal langsamer.
Also Zeitreisen, so wie
in "Interstellar" dargestellt,
ist theoretisch möglich,
es ist drastisch dargestellt.
Aber das Prinzip an sich
funktioniert.
Ob wir das noch erleben werden,
das kann nur die Zeit zeigen.
Wir haben
eine Menge Sachen besprochen.
Aber an denen klebt
noch das Wort "theoretisch" dran.
Es gibt
in der Wissenschaft auch Leute,
die das "theoretisch" ablehnen.
Die Zeitreisen nicht verschieben
oder unter Bedingungen stellen,
sondern grundsätzlich sagen,
das geht nicht, warum?
Das liegt daran,
dass Zeitreisen Probleme mit
der Kausalität mit sich bringen.
Dem Prinzip
von Ursache und Wirkung.
Ein bekanntes Beispiele dafür ist:
Wo man die Vergangenheit reist,
um seinen Großvater zu töten.
Und merkt,
dass man nicht geboren werden kann,
weil der Vater
dann auch nicht geboren wird.
Oder wie
bei "Zurück in die Zukunft",
wo Marty seine Mutter datet und
seine Existenz in Gefahr bringt.
Das siehst du beim:
Du reist in die Vergangenheit,
gehst zum Patentamt,
wo Einstein arbeitet, und erklärst
ihm die Relativitätstheorie.
Einstein findet das okay,
veröffentlicht das,
wird berühmt damit.
Und du in der Gegenwart lernst
die Relativitätstheorie im Studium.
Reist zurück zu Einstein,
erklärst ihm die.
Wo kam diese Informationen her?
Wer hat die Theorie
als Erstes erdacht?
Das sehen wir in vielen Fällen,
auch bei "Zurück in die Zukunft".
Marty spielt "Johnny B. Goode"
der Cousin von Chuck Berry hört das,
bringt es ihm bei, Cuck Berry
spielt den Song, Marty hört ihn.
Bei "Terminator" sehen wir Skynet,
die menschenfeindliche
Superintelligenz.
Die kann nur gebaut werden mit
Überresten von einem Terminator,
den Syknet aus der Zukunft
in die Vergangenheit schickt.
Das gleiche Problem.
Noch absurder wird es,
wenn wir nicht nur Ideen
durch die Zeit reichen,
sondern Gegenstände.
Dann gibt's ein Problem mit
dem 2. Hauptsatz der Thermodynamik:
Die Entropie, also die Unordnung im
Universum, wächst immer weiter an.
Du bekommst eine Uhr geschenkt,
reist in die Vergangenheit,
schenkst die Uhr jemandem.
Das ist die Person, von der du
später die Uhr geschenkt bekommst.
Das Objekt ist
in einer Zeitschleife gefangen
und nutzt sich immer weiter ab.
Dadurch,
dass die Entropie ansteigen muss.
Und irgendwann
würde diese Uhr kaputtgehen.
Das kann sie aber nicht,
weil sie in der Zeitschleife
vorhanden sein muss.
Auch der Energieerhaltungssatz
könnte verletzt werden
durch Zeitreisen.
Wir haben ein Portal, durch dieses
können wir einen Laser schießen,
von jetzt in die Vergangenheit.
In der Vergangenheit
steht ein Spiegel,
Laserstrahl
wird reflektiert in die Gegenwart.
Dort steht wieder ein Spiegel,
hin und her zwischen
Gegenwart und Vergangenheit.
Jetzt merkst du, es tauchen
immer mehr Laserstrahlen auf,
immer mehr Energie
auf beiden Seiten.
Das erlaubt eben
der Energieerhaltungssatz nicht.
Deswegen kann das nicht sein.
Darum gibt es Wissenschaftler,
die annehmen,
dass unser Universum,
die Gesetze der Naturwissenschaft,
fundamental
grundsätzlich verbieten,
dass es Zeitreisen geben kann.
Das finde ich spannend,
weil das heißt:
Diese Paradoxa
sind nicht nur Gedankenexperimente,
sondern hätten tatsächlich
Auswirkungen auf die Physik.
Ja, es gibt aber Hinweise darauf,
dass manche Paradoxa
in der Realität
gar keine Rolle spielen.
Dazu haben Forscher aus den USA
2020 ein cooles Experiment
mit Quantencomputern gemacht,
um im Bereich der Chaostheorie den
Butterfly-Effekt zu untersuchen.
Butterfly-Effekt
ist vereinfacht die Idee,
das der Flügelschlag
eines Schmetterlings
Ereignisse nach sich zieht,
die dazu führen,
dass an der anderen Seite der Welt
in Tornado entstehen kann.
In einem Film reist Ashton Kutscher
immer wieder in die Vergangenheit,
um Dinge zu verändern,
die eine katastrophale Verkettung
von Ereignissen auslösen,
die die Zukunft verändern.
Das scheint im Quantenbereich
eben nicht der Fall zu sein.
Was die Forscherinnen
und Forscher gemacht haben, ist,
sie haben
einen Quantencomputer genommen.
Der Vorteil
von Quantencomputern ist,
du kannst Systeme simulieren,
die du problemlos
rückwärts laufen lassen kannst.
Sie haben ein System simuliert,
sind in die Vergangenheit gereist,
haben die Zeit
rückwärts laufen lassen.
Haben in der Vergangenheit
eine kleine Veränderung,
eine kleine Verletzung im System
herbeigeführt.
Haben den Prozess dann
wieder vorwärts laufen lassen
und sich angeguckt, wie ändert
das die Jetztzeit, die Realität?
Sie haben gesehen:
Praktisch gar nicht.
Es hat sich fast nichts geändert.
Es scheint fast so,
als würde sich die Realität
selbst ausheilen.
Das Verrückte ist, je weiter sie
in die Vergangenheit gereist sind,
desto weniger Auswirkungen schien
es auf die Realität zu haben.
Beim Butterfly-Effekt würde man ja
den gegenteiligen Effekt erwarten.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall cool,
dass es überhaupt untersucht wird.
Es gibt noch die Theorie
des selbstkonsistenten Universums,
die Annahme, dass alles,
was in der Vergangenheit passiert,
wirklich schon passiert ist
und nicht änderbar ist.
Wenn du in die Vergangenheit
reisen könntest,
hätte diese Reise
schon stattgefunden.
Wenn du in die Vergangenheit reist,
wird diese zu deiner Zukunft.
Deine frühere Gegenwart
wird zur Vergangenheit,
die nicht nachträglich
verändert werden kann.
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist das:
Igor Nowikow ist ein Astrophysiker,
der die Annahme aufgestellt hat,
dass ein Ereignis, das so
ein Zeitparadoxon auslösen würde,
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist.
Das sehen wir häufiger in Filmen,
z.B. in "Harry Potter
und der Gefangene von Askaban".
Da reisen Harry und Hermine
mit dem Zeitumkehrer
in die Vergangenheit, um Sirius
und Seidenschnabel zu retten.
Als sie dort ankommen, merken sie,
sie können nichts verändern.
Denn alles, was sie machen,
ist in ihrer ehemaligen Gegenwart
auch schon passiert.
Hier wirft Hermine
einen Stein in Hagrids Wohnung,
was schon passiert ist,
bevor sie zurückgereist sind.
Auch das folgt diesem
Selbstübereinstimmungsprinzip.
Nowikow sagt, dass es
extrem unwahrscheinlich ist,
dass durch Zeitreisen
eine neue Physik entsteht,
wo Dinge auftauchen,
verschwinden oder sich auflösen.
Also selbst wenn Reinhardt
seinen Großvater umbringen wollte,
er könnte es gar nicht.
Eine gute Nachricht
für alle Großeltern,
aber auch unbefriedigend.
Das heißt ja,
dass der Lauf der Geschichte
vorbestimmt ist und unveränderbar.
Und damit auch der freie Wille
eingeschränkt ist.
Ich, als Zeitreisender, könnte nicht
handeln, wie ich handeln möchte.
Weiß nicht, ob mir das gefällt.
Freier Wille, überbewertet.
Ich glaube nicht ...
Vielen Leuten gefällt das nicht.
Deshalb gibt es
eine Menge andere Theorien.
Eine davon ist die Theorie
der vielen Welten oder Realitäten.
Dass jedes Mal, wenn man
eine Zeitreise machen würde,
etwas verändert,
ein neues Universum entsteht.
Das genauso ist wie das alte,
nur eine Sache geändert ist,
und sich unendlich
viele Welten daraus entwickeln.
Kennen wir
aus den Marvel-Filmen und -Serien.
Das haben wir schon besprochen,
in unserer Folge zum Multiversum.
Die verlinke ich euch mal hier oben.
Es gibt noch festzuhalten, dass die
Wissenschaft immer voranschreitet,
dass wir immer mehr herausfinden.
Das ist der Grund, warum wir
alle 2 Wochen Podcast machen,
warum es immer
neue faszinierende Sachen gibt.
Einstein selbst konnte sich
Schwarze Löcher nicht vorstellen.
Heute haben wir sie gemessen,
sogar Fotos davon gemacht.
Genauso hat man
das Higgs-Boson gefunden.
Man hat
Gravitationswellen gemessen.
Es gibt noch weiße Flecken
auf der Wissenschaftslandkarte.
Man arbeitet ja sehr hart daran,
die Quantenmechanik
und die Relativitätstheorie
zusammenzuführen.
Hätte man wieder eine
völlig andere Sicht auf die Welt,
einen erweiterten Blick
auf die Welt.
Gibt viel zu entdecken.
Wer weiß,
was man noch über Zeitreisen lernt?
Das ist der direkte Hinweis
an euch da draußen.
Bitte studiert Physik,
Mathe oder beides.
Helft uns dabei, das theoretische
Schlupfloch für Zeitreise zu finden.
I'm here to talk to you about
one of the most important weapon.
Vielen Dank fürs Erklären.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Wie hat euch die Folge gefallen?
Lasst einen Kommentar dazu da.
Und was ist
euer liebster Zeitreisefilm?
Packt ihn doch mal unten drunter.
Wir sagen noch danke
ans Turmuhren-Museum in Naunhof,
die haben uns hier drehen lassen.
Und wenn ihr es in der Vergangenheit
noch nicht getan habt,
dann denkt in der Zukunft daran,
diesen Kanal zu ...
Abonnieren.
Und die Glocke gedrückt zu haben.
Sein.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Wenn ihr noch Zeit habt,
klickt doch mal hier oben.
Da geht es zum Kanal
von "Minkorrekt!".
Da gibt's Physik und Experimente.
Und wenn ihr im Raum reisen wollt,
dann klickt hier.
Da haben unsere Kollegen
die Mission zum Mars gestartet.
Ein interaktives Hörspiel.
Copyright MDR 2022